I'm still very bullish on bitcoin  Bitcoin is the only asset right now  which looks interesting to me there's a  limited Supply which is very important  because the reason that we're in this  mess right now is because they were  printing endless amounts of money so  that's really important I look at  history so the last bull market we saw a  correction of 80 so if I was to use that  and predict what the bottom of this  Market could be it would come down to  around 13 600 however globally things  are a massive mess right now there's  still a war going on in Europe with  Russia and Ukraine we're seeing endless  amounts of money still being printed we  now have an energy crisis which means  that things are very bad basically  inflation is going crazy so I would  expect more Black Swan events to  potentially bring Bitcoin even lower  maybe around ten thousand dollars but  these are amazing buying opportunities